[Music]
what's surprising at least to scientists
is that the benefits for meditation show
up right from the beginning you can do
for example mindfulness that's very
popular meditation if you do mindfulness
practice ten minutes a day or ten
minutes three times over the course of a
day something remarkable happens to your
attention and that's the fact that it
has to do with the fact that we're all
multitasking these days you know people
on average look at their email about 50
times a day they look at their Facebook
20-some times a day and that's just the
tip of the iceberg there's Instagram
there's your phone calls there's
whatever it is you have to do and what
this means for attention is that we're
challenged that focused attention is an
endangered species however we need that
focus to get work done well so it's a
it's a real problem and meditation that
turns out even at the beginning has some
of the answer it goes like this when
you're really intensely focused on that
one thing you have to do or you want to
do the the paper you're writing or the
project you're working on then you think
oh I better check my email and then that
leads to your Facebook and that leads to
the phone call Lisa we call this
multitasking the brain actually does not
do multitasking doesn't do several
things at once in in parallel rather it
works in serial and it switches very
rapidly from one thing to the next then
when you go back to that project or that
whatever it was you're so focused on but
your concentration had been at a very
high level before you started doing the
other things now it's much lower and it
takes a while to ramp up to that same
level unless and this is so interesting
unless you've done that ten minutes of
mindfulness focused on your breath for
example just watched it in and out I
noticed when your mind wandered brought
it back that's the basic move in
meditation and if you do that it turns
out just ten minutes of practice
nullifies that loss of concentration and
this works for example for people who
might do mindfulness of the
morning it will wane during the course
of the day but if you do 10 more minutes
at lunch ten more minutes at a break in
the mid-afternoon it helps you through
the day stay concentrated so that is a
very palpable concrete payoff from daily
meditation though it works for beginners
there are there are many others too for
example in terms of handling stress I
mean we're all stressed out these days
and beginners in mindfulness or other
meditations it turns out right from the
get-go have a better reaction to stress
what that means is that and we see this
in brain function the area of the brain
which reacts to stress called the
amygdala it's the trigger point for the
fight or flight or freeze response it's
what makes us angry all of a sudden or
anxious all of a sudden the amygdala is
quieter it's calmer in the face of
stress and this lets us be calmer in the
face of stress and this is another
benefit that we see right from the
beginning because meditation has been
found to work so well with anxiety and
depression and possibly PTSD or that's
being looked into one of the areas that
seems promising is meditation with
attention deficit disorder in a way this
is a no-brainer because at base in
essence every kind of meditation
retrains
attention and what attention deficit
disorder is is a problem with attention
so there's now a whole host of studies
underway that you mainly with kids
because it's where a TD tends to show up
first where they're helping them
strengthen the muscle of attention and
you can I I was in a classroom of seven
year olds in Spanish Harlem this is a
very impoverished area of New York City
and those kids live in housing projects
they're very troubled lives and some of
them had a DD in fact half the kids in
that classroom had what are called
special needs ranging from a DD to
autism
I thought the classroom would be totally
chaotic
actually the kids were calm and focused
and the teacher said here's why and then
they did their daily ritual of what they
call belly buddies they each child one
by one went to their cubby got a
favorite little stuffed animal found a
place to lie down on a rug put that
animal on their belly and then they
listened to a tape that guided them
through watching the belly rise on the
in-breath fall on the out-breath one two
three on the in-breath one two three on
the out-breath this is basically the
beginning of mindfulness or meditation
for kids you know in cognitive science
would say this is the training of
attention so you can do it with very
young kids and this helps them get
stronger in their ability to concentrate
attention deficit disorder is basically
not being able to control your mind
wandering off from what you're paying
attention to every time you watch your
belly rise and then your mind wanders
off and you bring it back to your belly
you're strengthening the neural
circuitry for focus and countering mind
wandering so this seems very promising
in early studies early pilots show that
this may well counter the problems kids
face in a didi and I'm very happy to say
that major studies are underway we're
waiting for those results but I think
they're promising
[Music]